foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's go
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I love you
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
hi everyone
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
everything
something
you can escape
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
today
to the students of the class of 2022 and
their parents families and friends
welcome to the
321st commencement of Yale University
We Gather to recognize the extraordinary
accomplishments of all of you who have
worked so hard to complete your programs
of study
We Salute your effort
your diligence your talent and your
intellect
we also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported you in these
endeavors
your families
friends teachers and other members of
the Yale community
in keeping with the tradition of this
occasion I now call on the University
chaplain to offer an invocation
to the Quinnipiac people for this land
on which we stand
my beloved Yale family I invite you to
join me in the spirit of Prayer
Almighty and loving creator
you are the force that lights the Stars
the architect of every cell the source
of all truth
we stand in the dazzling beauty of this
morning as many expressions of one
living mystery a mystery beyond all
telling
we who share this beautiful but aching
world we who look at the same sun and
the same moon are a people called to
communal restoration
as students of your handiwork we have
gathered here from throughout the Earth
with exquisite Ambitions and have been
blessed in this place of light and Truth
with the freedom to let them grow
Our God of all generations you are the
guardian of where we are going and who
we are becoming
as we prepare to take leave of this
place
may we exude an intelligence that is
inspired by Justice Guided by tenderness
moved by Holiness and always informed by
love
from this moment of awe and Beyond fill
our hearts with an imaginative daring
one that stirs us to become vibrant
living examples of Shalom of Salam
Ashanti of peace
together let us say Amen
please be seated
yep
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for the bachelor's degrees in Yale
College
for the degree of Bachelor of Arts
861 in number
and for the degree of Bachelor of
Science
518 in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of Yale College and approved by
the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees
all right
it's a little bit of pent-up energy
today
you think maybe we haven't done this in
a couple of years
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the bachelor's degrees in Yale
College as designated by the dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
thank you
[Applause]
right here
[Applause]
congratulations
[Applause]
congratulations
congratulations
bye baby
[Music]
and congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the School of
Architecture
for the degree
master of architecture 73 in numbered
and for the degree master of
environmental design four in number they
have been recommended by The Faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in architecture and
design as designated by the dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
foreign
[Applause]
Mr President I have the honor to
recognize
graduates for degrees in the School of
Art for the degree of Master of Fine
Arts 49 in number they were recommended
by The Faculty of the school and
approved by the corporation and they
were conferred degrees by your official
Act
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degree in art as designated
by the dean and admit you to all its
rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the David
Geffen School of drama
[Applause]
[Music]
for the certificate in drama
six in number
for the degree of Master of Fine Arts 34
in number and for the degree of doctor
of Fine Arts three in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you about your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
[Music]
by the authority vested in me
I confer upon you the certificate and
degrees in drama as designated by the
dean and admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
thank you congratulations
congratulations
whoops congratulations
[Applause]
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the School of
Music
for the certificate in performance three
in number
for the artist's diploma 2 in number
for the degree of Master Of Music 58 in
number
for the degree of Master of musical arts
38 in number
and for the degree of doctor of musical
arts 14 in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
[Applause]
your quick studies
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the certificate diploma and
degrees in music as designated by the
dean and admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations
congratulations
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the School of
Nursing
for the degree of master of science in
nursing
114 in number
for the postmaster certificate in
nursing one in number and for the degree
of doctor of nursing practice 18 in
number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in nursing as
designated by the dean and admit you to
all their rights and responsibilities
congratulations
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the school of
the environment
[Music]
for the degree of Master of
Environmental Management
117 in number for the degree of Master
of environmental science 20 in number
for the degree of Master of Forestry
seven in number and for the degree of
Master of forest science two in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and improved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in environment and
Forestry as designated by the dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
congratulations
congratulations
congratulations
congratulations
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for degrees in the School of Management
for the degree of Master of business
administration
387 in number
for the degree of Master of advanced
management 56 in number
and for the degree of Master and
management studies
151 in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them
thank you
[Applause]
a nice collaborative effort Mr Dean
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in management as
designated by the dean and admit you to
all their rights and responsibilities
congratulations
congratulations
congratulations
congratulations
congratulations
congratulations
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for degrees in the Divinity School
for the degree of master of arts in
religion 70 in number for the degree of
Master of divinity 59 in number and for
the degree of Master of sacred theology
six in number they have been recommended
by The Faculty of the school and
approved by the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in religion
Divinity and theology as designated by
the dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the law school
for the degree of Masters in law 38 in
number
for the degree of Master Of Studies of
law three in number
for the degree of doctor the science of
law five in number and for the degree of
Juris doctor 206 in number
[Applause]
when they have been recommended by the
faculty
and approved by the corporation I shall
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me I shall
confer upon you the degrees in the law
school when designated by the dean and
shall then admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
meanwhile congratulations
congratulations
congratulations
hey
congratulations
congratulations
thank you
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for degrees in The Graduate School
for the degree of Master Of Studies 10
in number for the degree of master of
science
271 in number
for the degree of master of arts 255 in
number and for the degree in master of
philosophy
436 in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in The Graduate
School as designated by the dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
congratulations
[Applause]
congratulations
and congratulations
[Applause]
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the School of
Public Health
for the degree of Master of Public
Health 184 in number they have been
recommended by The Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the degree in public health as
designated by the dean and admit you to
all its rights and responsibilities
congratulations
[Applause]
Mr President
I have the honor to present candidates
for degrees in the school of medicine
for the degree of Master of Medical
Science 104 in number when they shall
have been recommended by The Faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation I shall ask by your official
act to confer upon them this degree
for the degree
of Master of Health Science 32 in number
and for the degree of doctor in medicine
98 in number
they have been recommended by The
Faculty of the school and have and
approved by the corporation I now ask
you by your official act to confer upon
them
please
by the authority vested in me I shall
confer the degree in medical science and
do confer upon you the degrees in health
science and medicine as designated by
the dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
congratulations
clarissimay candidate
Sofia doctors
numero cantum quattor decum TV price
Santo
a facultate Philadelphia Artie um
academico illustri Opera party soon
admit us
[Applause]
and Mito
chitis
confero
nunk studies
absolutist ego places
was ex-animal your bell salware
[Applause]
please rise
us
praise
is
[Music]
Justice
[Music]
foreign
we will now proceed to the awarding of
honorary degrees
the ten individuals we honor this
morning serve as examples to you our
graduates
to encourage you to Aspire to Excellence
and to Value those elements of human
character
that they embody
creativity
curiosity
discipline integrity and a passion for
public service
their presence here also honors you
who graduate today
and all of us who are here to salute you
but now as his customary call upon the
Provost
to prevent to present the candidates for
honorary degrees
Mr President
I have the honor to present the
candidates for honorary degrees
for the degree of doctor of Humane
letters in memoriam
Madeleine K Albright diplomat
Jake Watson Yale College Class of 2022
is accepting his grandmother's degree on
behalf of the Albright family
scholar States woman stalwart voice of
democracy
Coming to America as a child she
embodied the American dream
breaking barriers in her political
career
and promoting human rights for all
with strategic policies and her
statement pins she guided peacekeeping
efforts around the globe with courage
conviction and Flair
in gratitude for her public service and
admiration for her leadership Yale is
pleased to confer posthumously this
doctor of Humane letters degree on
Madeline K Albright
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of science
Drew Weissman immunologist
we regret that Dr Weissman cannot be
here with us today
pioneering scientists
doctor of Distinction
his efforts to unlock the potential of
the human immune system have reshaped
our lives and help us to Envision a
post-pandemic future
his discoveries made it possible to
enlist messenger RNA in a vaccine form
teaching our bodies how to defend
themselves against infection
and laying the foundation for medical
Innovations still to come
with gratitude for his groundbreaking
research Yale has the pleasure of
conferring on him this doctor of Science
degree
[Applause]
for the doctor of humanities Jill lapor
historian
public scholar of the highest caliber
in your writings teaching and research
you illuminate the hidden corners of our
shared history
your gift says a Storyteller are matched
by your Deft navigation of archival
Records
you have shown us that these truths are
our truths Paving the way for dialogue
and deeper understanding
voice of wear attacks and of Lux
in recognition of your insights and
intellect we are privileged to present
your second yell degree doctor of
humanities
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of laws Myron H
Thompson jurist
[Applause]
audacious Advocate and learned legal
scholar you have made Justice both a
career and a calling
in the courtroom you tenaciously defend
Equity Liberty and dignity for all
in the classroom you teach others to
walk the same path
your long service to your home state
inspires us your commitment to your alma
mater humbles us
as a testament to your impact and with
utmost pleasure we award you your third
Yale degree doctor of laws
for the degree of doctor of medical
Sciences Gene Bennett physician
scientist
[Applause]
trailblazing daughter of Yale and New
Haven
your vision for novel therapeutic
treatments has restored vision for those
who had lost it
shifting paradigms and practice you
brought the possibilities of gene
therapy from concept to reality giving
New Hope to Pediatric patients and
others affected by congenital disorders
with Acuity and acumen
you have set our sights toward a
brighter future
Maverick and mentor we are proud to
present you your second Yale degree
doctor of Medical Science
for the degree of doctor of social
science Orlando Patterson
cultural sociologists
[Applause]
esteemed educator and trusted advisor
your scholarship has shaped our
perceptions of Freedom slavery poverty
and even Athletics
your influence transcends the academy
to make a vital difference in
strengthening communities in your
birthplace Jamaica you have helped to
direct Aid and attention where they are
needed most from The Shanty towns of
Kingston to schools across the country
with reverence joy and more than a
little awe Yale presents you with this
degree of doctor of social science
for the degree of doctor of Music
Caroline Shaw musician
shape-shifting chantus your virtuosity
as a musician is rivaled only by your
neck for Creative collaboration
defying convention you have drawn on
diverse traditions and influences to
produce genres and Melodies that are all
your own
orange and Evergreen blue as the sky and
deep as the narrow sea
for opening our ears to sounds
heretofore unheard and for engaging a
new era of listeners we are delighted to
confer your second yell degree doctor of
music
congratulations
for the degree of doctor of science
Catalan carico biochemist
[Applause]
resilient in your pursuit to expand the
boundaries of knowledge you stood
unwavering against challenges and
skepticism
after learning of the mechanisms of
messenger RNA you knew that its
capacities could be channeled for the
greater good
you stayed the course
and your perseverance has transformed a
beleaguered world
an appreciation for your life-saving
work yell is honored to bestow upon you
this doctor of Science degree
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of divinity
Krista Tippett journalist
convener of conversation
in bringing spirituality into the
spotlight you raise our spirits and
reveal our common Humanity
your podcast is your pulpit and the
world is your congregation
with wisdom Candor and fearlessness in
broaching the big questions of meaning
you invite us to imagine a new way of
being and of living
one that celebrates our
interconnectedness
Intrepid interlocutor for your fluency
with faith we recognize you with your
second Yale degree doctor of divinity
for the degree of doctor of Humane
letters James E Clyburn public servant
champion of civil rights and preserver
of Our National History
you galvanized your generation and have
inspired those that followed
beginning in your early years as a
student activist you have been a
catalyst for change steadfast in your
dedication to bettering the lives of
your fellow citizens
you have worn many hats educator advisor
legislator role model
hero and humanist we welcome you to the
Yale family with this degree of doctor
of Humane letters
[Applause]
please rise
yeah
[Music]
the more
[Music]
our heart is
[Music]
soft
[Music]
we put our lives
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I invite you to bow with me as we offer
one more blessing on these graduates
God of Mystery
you are other
yet we are in your likeness
you are Beyond
yet you are within
you are imperceptible
yet you are known
as we send these graduates into an
unknown future
grant them the vision to see the Divine
in all
open their hearts to write the
injustices
that we have not overcome
Enlighten their eyes to see
what no one has perceived
for the joy of life
in the presence of death
for the thrill of embodied community
for the hope of a future that this event
promises
we thank you and ask you to bless these
graduates their families and our
community amen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign